club pl bonjour bonjour monsieur les
oreilles vous êtes candidat à cette
marie et vous allez conduire la liste
cohésion constructive
vous avez 53 ans et vous êtes policier
c'est ça tout est exact qu'est ce qui
vous motive alors à 20 ce qui me motive
actuellement et depuis quelques années
déjà c'est la situation dans laquelle se
trouve ma commune la commune des
samaritains notre fierté a disparu nous
sommes dans une situation économique
déplorable
nous avons des habitants qui quittent la
ville nous avons une situation qui se
trouve extrêmement compliqué parce que
ce que nous annonce n'est pas ce que
l'on constate
nous avons des gens qui n'osent même pas
parler nous avons des agents
administratifs qui sont dans la
souffrance
enfin c'est tout ça c'est tout ça qui
m'a qui m'a dit avec une qui m'a
interpellé
et avec un groupe nous avons décider
vraiment de nous mettre à la disposition
de notre commune pour la faire avancer
et ça passe forcément par des élections
municipales alors en 2017 lors de
l'élection partielle vous aviez tenté de
rassembler les opposants au maire
sortant et ça a été un échec mais vous
nous aviez vous aviez jeter l'épongé
à cette époque il cette année non plus
ce n'est pas le cas il ya pas de
rassemblement il n'y a pas d'union
caisse comment vous expliquez cela alors
à la place de mon échec je dirais ça a
été un tour raté effectivement donc je
me suis rapproché de tous les candidats
qui étaient en lice sauf le maire sort
très bien évidemment puisque l'objectif
était de faire un tronc commun pour
pouvoir combattre ce système en place
effectivement ça n'a pas fonctionné ce
qui n'a pas fonctionné sur le mois parce
que il y avait peut-être des guerres de
chapelles chacun voulait y aller et je
me suis retiré ce n'est pas un échec
pour moi au contraire c'était une
manière de me dire ok on se retire on
prend du recul on laisse faire il
reviendra en 2020 ce que je fais
aujourd'hui en 2020 en jeu en 2020 est
ce que vous ne paierez pas tous je dis
quand je dis tous je dis tous les
candidats deuxième tour pour vous
rassemblez alors je vais peut-être vous
étonner
monsieur livory c'est qu'en 2020 je
pense qu'il n'aura pas de deuxième tour
hassan
moi j'en ai la conviction pourquoi je
dis ça parce que j'entends les gens sur
dans mes porte à porte
j'ai contact avec la population et on
s'est rendu compte que les gens en ont
marre ils ont besoin de changer les
choses rapidement est d'autant plus que
la situation ne permet pas qu'on aille
encore un deuxième tour maintenant une
fois de plus j'ai tenté de me rapprocher
des autres mais ça l'a toujours pas
marché donc c'est pour cette raison on a
décidé avec le groupe cohésion
constructive avec l'ensemble des
samaritains de mettre en oeuvre tout
pour pouvoir aller le 15 mars 2020 à las
de cette mairie mais tout simplement si
pour réconcilier samaritain et mettre en
oeuvre des techniques mettre en oeuvre
un dispositif qui permettra à la ville
d'évoluer correctement quand vous dites
qu'il n'y aura pas de deuxième tour à
sept maris ça veut dire que vous pensez
que bruno nestor azérot sera élu dès le
premier tour
non moi je pense tout simplement que le
groupe cohésion constructive avec
l'autre coppel à la tête de ce groupe
sera élu dès le premier tour
maintenant s'il s'avère qu'il ya un
deuxième tour ce que je ne souhaite pas
parce que cette marie assez perdu de
temps
cette maria assez souffert des promesses
non tenues ddd des semblants de
fonctionnement des et comme le disait la
chambre régionale des comptes
nous sommes face à une municipalité qui
travaille à la petite semaine
il faut vraiment avoir une vision pour
notre ville il faut avoir des projets
qui vont porter et c'est pour ça que
cohésion constructive sur la présence
élections et on donne rendez vous le 15
mars aux samaritains
alors justement quels sont les grands
lits les grandes lignes de votre
programme
alors juste les grandes lignes parce
qu'en cinq minutes c'est pas facile de
dire de tout dire mais vous savez ce qu
ont la priorité pour l'instant ce sera
de redynamiser redynamiser ckoi
économiquement nous devons faire en
sorte que cette marie soit le tiroir
soit une pépinière pour permettre aux
porteurs de projets venus s'installer
cette maille a besoin de vivre les
commerçants besoin de vivre bien sûr on
pourrait parler du social on le fera par
jouer c'est très rapide mais une
priorité des priorités c'est faire en
sorte que la ville soit accessible que
l'on vienne de trinité convient de de
marigot que cette marie redevienne ce
qu'elle a été dans temps là captait de
north atlantic et ça c'est notre
passionné pas ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui être travaux dans le bon bah
écoute et effectivement il ya des
travaux dans le bourg
court mais bon alors des travaux car
dans le bourg ce n'est pas dans le but
de développer la commune
désolé de vous l'apprendre les travaux
qu'il ya dans le bourg et simplement
nous sommes en train l'équipe en place
l'équipe municipale en place est en
train de répondre à une obligation
légale du gouvernement de construire des
logements alors que c'est pas l'équipe
en place et construit ce qui se passe en
ce moment c'est que les travaux dans le
bourg ne permettent pas de développement
économique
les travaux d'un bourg ne permettent pas
aux gens de se sentir bien ne permettons
pas aux gens de faire fonctionner la
commune câlin toma n'entend donc c'est
pour cette raison que nous laissons
faire les choses mais je dis aux samares
état soyez vigilants ne vous laissez pas
avoir une troisième fois
parce que depuis 12 ans je pense que ça
suffit il est temps que cette maric
grandissent et accède à son statut qu'il
convient capitale nord atlantique claude
copé elle je vous remercie
c'est moi bonne soirée